foreign
of the city by the bay create an ad to
deny the town's disgusting Decay Frisco
leaders just launched a glitzy six
million dollar ad campaign to boost
tourism ahead of the summer travel
season although residents say that money
could have been better spent on one
public toilet
the beautiful new ad takes you on a
joyous tour of their City meanwhile the
television crew had to keep yelling cut
when another crew member got stabbed
but you got dancing in the streets Sleek
bars with sexy women drinking martinis
and visions of perfectly seared scallops
doused in light cream sauce at least I
hope that's cream sauce
yeah I know disgusting but the beauty of
the video it's not scratch and sniff or
you'd be wretching but also it's not
true it's all much better with sound so
watch
welcome to the most beautiful city in
the world where it's never the same but
always San Francisco
[Music]
foreign
wow I saw some white people in there
what's going on anyway so rather than
solve the problems of rampant crime
homelessness and violence they figure a
PR campaign might do the trick this is a
case where they literally are trying to
paint a turd
visitor numbers are still way down
compared to pre-pandemic levels it's so
bad even covid cleared out because it
didn't feel safe there so from our
perspective this is less a commercial
and more than unintentional comedy skit
featuring propaganda as believable as
the view doing a show on how to please
your man
but it doesn't really capture the spirit
of San France so we fixed it for them
welcome to the home of Urban Decay by
the bay but what some call blight
all right
San Francisco this place is covered in
poo but it's free poo you can use to
fertilize your garden San Francisco
there's needles all around they're great
for sewing or learning acupuncture San
Francisco you get robbed every day but
you come to learn you don't need money
anyway San Francisco plenty of homeless
camps but don't despair they get fresh
air and nature is cool hey
yes
I want to go I want to go Liz do you
think that PR video is gonna help No it
should have come with a travel advisory
warning it's like bring your bring your
disinfected come to San Francisco
thinking and how many millions do they
blow on that six million I mean it's
unbelievable and then you know we I'm
telling you I have friends I've cut my
family live in the Bay Area they're
astounded at how rapidly it turned into
a retail desert I mean you're talking
major stores like Nordstrom sex you know
Office Depot Banana Republic Old Navy
fleeing and leaving and it is in a state
of decay and to collapse and you know
it's it's such an object lesson it takes
so long to turn these stories around it
takes it like a switch you can turn a
city overnight into to a wasteland how
fresh it's fragile and it takes a hell
of a long time to bring it back it's so
funny banned a republic leaving a Banana
Republic Tyrant I was thinking we should
do a road trip what if we did all five
shows in San Francisco for a week oh I'd
get covered yeah
[Applause]
um
the cat would get pregnant yeah
all right I'm actually nine months
pregnant
the right time to tell you guys
it's just came on so quick but I'm gonna
be out for three months
and I think the father's coveted so you
can have that like six months the first
coveted babies coming so
uh yeah I really can't top that um
but the commercial is it never allows
you to actually focus on what they're
showing you it's all shot from drones
and it's like 7
go check it out
yeah street level
low or the side and you can never see
anything around them look
and what that means is every time they
film somebody who was not paid to be on
set strolled through yeah so that's so
don't fall for that like that's
literally yeah and it's probably
San Diego California that they're doing
this in
it does look like San Diego so yeah I
would be real careful like if you're
gonna go to the new Afghanistan
look at the new Afghanistan before like
realize what it's going to be Kat it is
true they're selling things at every
city you could find that anywhere
they're like we have scallops
except also our scallops are three
hundred dollars like San Francisco is
also heck inexpensive yeah so that's the
that's a it's the combination of all the
stuff everyone's already brought up and
the fact that it will cost a lot more to
have your conference there than it would
to have it in a normal place without all
the poop
[Music]
which I think is important to a lot of
people it is yeah it is a guy you told
me in the Green Room that poop in San
Francisco was unlike that of any other
major city care to elaborate I think it
speaks for itself Craig
and In fairness like yes they did a lot
of these outdoor shots using drone
cameras it's because all of the normal
cameras that they had on the street had
been stolen yes right so they had to
like put them in the sky so they can't
take them you know it's bad in San
Francisco when they have to close a
Whole Foods in a ritzy neighborhood
white rich San franciscans love nothing
more than Whole Foods but it was too
dangerous to operate they opened it and
closed it about a year later there was
like a 911 call every day that is a sad
State of Affairs and they're trying to
figure out how to sort of skirt around
that with this little flashy glitzy ad
Campaign which is going to be juxtaposed
with news stories coming out of San
Francisco which may hold a little bit
more weight with the intended audience
so do
let's just stay in one place and that's
why they don't care it's like how does
Gavin Newsom like wake up in the morning
and not feel like a pilot because he was
mayor he was mayor of San Francisco he's
the governor of California he's never
there do they just deliberately ignore
these areas yeah they may not he may not
feel like a pilot but he accidentally
stepped in one uh when he left his house
but the thing is he is in a cloistered
Place surrounded by armed security so
he's fine almost everyone else is not so
fine yeah and you've got to bring in
fresh victims yeah there go the
commercial yes that's true but don't
worry guys I'm gonna fix it how we're
going to bring new people in for them to
Rob yeah
amazing and as cat said scallops
scallops
all right
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else